ne cherchez pas le maire de montréal ces
jours ci denis coderre entamé une
mission commerciale d'une ampleur
inégalée en chine en compagnie de 70
personnes
la délégation va s'arrêter dans cinq
villes d'ici vendredi
il vend le mercredi sera donc un ordre
du jour chargé surtout à compter de ce
lundi
aujourd'hui pour vous voilà pascal on
peut vraiment dire que les missions
économiques du mercredi qui commence
officiellement aujourd'hui alors qu'il
se rend à shanghai la ville la plus
importante en chine la plus populeuse
mais surtout le coeur financier du pays
et c'est vraiment là bas que le maire
coderre compte faire le plein de
contrats
on sait qu'il est accompagné de 70
personnes des gens du milieu des
affaires du milieu de la culture du
milieu de l'enseignement de grandes
compagnies snc-lavalin des banques aussi
c'est la plus importante délégation de
l'histoire pour la ville de montréal
dans un pays étranger
pour le moment le mercredi air et son
équipe qui ne veulent pas parler du
nombre de contrats ni du montant des
investissements qui devrait être paraphé
au cours des prochains jours mais on
nous dit que ce soit important et
surtout que les retombées s'étaleront
sur plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois
voire même des années
mais l'autre volet de cette mission
c'est de renouveler l'entente de
partenariat entre montréal et la ville
de shannon wright un jumelage qui
s'était fait il y a trente ans et si à
ce moment là c'était al'avantage de
shangai d'avoir un partenaire du côté
d'une ville de leur silence comme
montréal
aujourd'hui je vous dirais que c'est
plutôt l'inversé mauriac qui a tout à
gagner dans ce partenariat avec la ville
de shanghai shanghai ce qui est assez
simple c'est devenu l'une des villes les
plus importantes sur la planète
merci beaucoup et 20 au revoir